So here is our stage manager approval process. And
if I scroll down, so I've got these initial
submission actions, approval steps, final approval actions, final rejection
actions, all these different things. What's, what's going on here?
>> So actions and approvals are the same thing as they are in work flows,
you know, creating an email, or sending
an email, creating a task, updating a field.
>> Okay.
>> But the great thing about approval processes, you can add
in actions throughout all the steps of the process.
>> Okay.
>> So initial submission actions are the actions that
are fired immediately after someone submits a record for approval.
>> Okay.
>> The approval steps are the pieces of the flow that,
you know, happen as it's going down the line of approvers.
>> Mm.
>> Cause you could have one approver, just one manager. Or, you could send it
down a list of managers if you wanted a bunch of people to approve it.
>> Sure.
>> Then there's the final approval actions, which
is after either the last person approves it.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Rejects it, or maybe somewhere along the way, someone
was like, recall this approval, like, I want to take it back.
>> Okay.
>> And so you can set up.
>> all your actions.
>> Actions for all the parts of the flow.
>> Very cool. Okay, that makes sense.